debate every finding compared to
existing science and literature
weighing the risks and benefits of every
intervention its timing
as any as well as any potential impacts
a delay
may have over the course of his illness
the president has experienced two
episodes of transient drops
in his oxygen saturation we debated the
reasons for this
and whether we'd even intervene is it
determination of the team based
predominantly on the timeline from the
initial diagnosis
that we initiate dexamethasone i'd like
to take this opportunity now
given some speculation over the course
of the illness now the last couple days
uh update you on the course of his own
illness
thursday night into friday morning when
i left the bedside the president was
doing well
with only mild symptoms and his oxygen
was in the high 90s
late friday morning when i returned to
the bedside president had a high fever
and his oxygen oxygen saturation was
transiently dipping
below 94 given these two developments i
was concerned for possible rapid
progression of the illness
i recommended the president we try some
supplemental oxygen
see how he'd respond he was fairly
adamant that he didn't need it
he was not short of breath he was tired
had the fever and that was about it
and after about a minute on only two
liters
his saturation levels were back over 40
over 95 percent
stayed on that for about an hour maybe
and it was off and gone later that day
by the time the team here was at the
bedside president had been up out of bed
moving about the residence with only
mild symptoms
despite this everyone agreed the best
course of action was to move to walter
reed
for more thorough evaluation monitoring
now i'd like to invite up dr dooley
discuss current plan
thank you dr connolly um before i begin
a brief clinical update on the
president's condition i do want to
reiterate my comments from yesterday
regarding the uh how proud i am to be a
part of this multi-disciplinary
multi-institutional team of clinical
professionals behind me
and what an honor it is to care for the
president uh here at walter reed
national military medical center
regarding his clinical status the
patient continues to
improve he has remained without fever
since friday morning his vital signs are
stable
from a pulmonary standpoint he remains
on room air this morning
and is not complaining of shortness of
breath or other significant respiratory
symptoms he's ambulating
himself walking around the white house
medical unit
without limitation or disability
our continued monitoring of his
cardiac liver and kidney function
demonstrates continued normal findings
or improving findings
i'll now turn it over to dr garibaldi
from johns hopkins to talk about
our therapeutics and again our plan for
the day
thank you dr dooley and i just wanted to
again reiterate what an honor and a
privilege it is to take care of the
president but to be part of such a
talented and multi-disciplinary team
here at
walter reed uh the president yesterday
evening completed his second dose of
remdessevier
he's tolerated that infusion well we've
been monitoring for any potential side
effects
and he has had none that we can tell his
liver and kidney function have remained
normal
and we continue uh to plan to use a
five-day course of rem deserve
in response to transient low oxygen
levels as dr
conley has discussed we did initiate
dexamethasone therapy
and he received his first dose of that
yesterday and our plan is to continue
that for the time being
today he feels well he's been up and
around our plan for today is to have him
to eat and drink
be up out of bed as much as possible to
be mobile
and if he continues to look and and feel
as well as he does today our hope is
that we can plan for a discharge as
early as tomorrow
to the white house where he can continue
his treatment course thank you very much
and i'll turn over to dr connelly for
any questions
just a moment please
president wanted me to share how proud
he is of the group
what an honor it is for him to be
receiving his care here at walter reed
surrounded by such incredible talent
academic leaders
department chairs internationally
renowned researchers and clinicians
including the support of dr garibaldi
from johns hopkins
um i'd like to reiterate how pleased we
all are
with the president's recovery and with
that i'll take your question
thank you doctor you said that there
were two instances where he had drops in
oxygen can you walk us through the
second one and also i've got a question
for the lung specialist afterwards sure
yeah
yeah yesterday there was another episode
where he dropped down
about 93 percent um he doesn't ever feel
short of breath
uh we watched it um and it returned back
up um as i said we evaluate all of these
and given the timeline where he is in
the the course of illness
you know we we're trying to maximize
everything uh that we could do for him
and
we debated whether we'd even start it uh
the dex
dexamethasone and we decided that in
this case
the potential benefits early on the
course probably outweighed any risks at
this time
did you give him a second round of
supplemental oxygen yesterday
uh i'd have to i'd have to check with
the nursing staff
i don't think that if he did it was very
very limited uh but
it's not on oxygen um and the only
oxygen that i ordered
that we provided was uh that friday
morning initially
and about what time was that yesterday
uh
yesterday what was yesterday you said
the second instance second
incidents oh it was over the course of
the day yeah yesterday morning
dr coleman president's current uh blood
oxygen level that's my first question to
you dr conley
98 and what do the uh x-rays
and ct scans show are there signs
of pneumonia are there signs of lung
involvement
or any damage to the lungs yeah so we're
tracking all of that
um there's some expected findings but
nothing of uh
any major clinical concern then why
start him doctor finally on the
expression
his oxygen level ever dipped below 90.
uh we don't have any recordings here of
that that's right the
dexter method yeah what about here at
the white house or here
anything below 90 just to follow up on
her question uh no it was below 94
it was it wasn't down in the low 80s or
anything so okay so on the dexa method
the the steroids sir on the left you
told us that the president was in great
shape
had been in good shape and fever-free
for the previous 24 hours
minutes after your press conference
white house chief of staff mark meadows
told reporters that the president's
vitals were very concerning over the
past 24 hours
simple question for the american people
whose statements about the president's
health should be believed
so the chief and i worked side by side
and i think his statement was
misconstrued what he meant
was that 24 hours ago
when uh he and i were are checking on
the president that there was that
momentary episode of the high fever
and and that temporary drop uh in the
saturation
which prompted us to act uh
expediently to move him up here
fortunately
that was really a very transient limited
episode
a couple hours later he was back up uh
mild again
um you know we i'm not going to
speculate what that
that limited episode was about so early
in the course but he's doing well what
are the expected findings on his lungs
and why is the president not wearing a
mask in the videos and photos that have
been released
well the the president uh wears a mask
anytime he's
he's around us and we're all wearing our
uh n95s
full ppe um he's he's the patient and
when we can
when he'll move out into uh to public we
move him about out and around other
people
that aren't in full ppe i assure you
he'll as long as he's
still under my care uh we'll talk about
him wearing him and he's in a negative
pressure room
and the room is negative i'm not going
to get into the specifics of uh his care
and can you answer the questions around
the lung function
question dr conley i'm sorry the lung
function question can you talk about
that and what are these expectations i
would just share that
like every patient we perform lung in
spirometry on him
and uh he's maxing it out we told him uh
see what you can do
and it's over 2500 milliliters each time
he's doing great yeah showing any
irregularities in his lungs are there
any okay
today to disclose that the president had
been administered
oxygen uh it's a good question so
i was trying to reflect the the uh the
upbeat attitude that the
team the president that his course of
illness has had
um didn't want to give any uh
any information that might uh the the
course of illness in another direction
um and in doing so uh you know it came
off
uh that we were trying to hide something
which wasn't necessarily true um
and uh so here i have it he's he is the
effect of the matter is is that he's
doing really well that he is he is
uh responding and as the team said uh if
everything continues to go well
we're going to start discharge planning
back to the white house
that's it thank you dr connolly on his
lung scans
this is again you did this yesterday can
you please explain what you found on his
lung scans
hey chief you
that wanna as fun as yesterday